shirish catfish did release of the other
difficulty is however that we have to
reconcile two things on the one hand an
ambitious and impressive progress on
climate change and reducing co2
emissions that has to be reconciled with
the fact that in many European countries
not just in Germany in neighboring
countries as well the automobile
industry has and plays an important role
big contribution towards prosperity and
GDP in the interest of efficiency and
competitiveness of European car industry
and we are an important part of that
industry it is necessary to find a
balanced compromise a balance between
efficiency competitiveness and at the
same time climate change targets
industry have to flourish in Europe in
European Union it is the best way for
the industry and it is also the best way
for the environment so I think we should
link competitiveness and environment or
aware of the concerns expressed by other
countries in particular by Germany is
the leading car manufacturer in Europe
we're prepared to be constructive
there's no point complaining about
what's happened to the past water under
the bridge we can't ignore existing
realities we need to get beyond the
sticking points at the moment but not at
any cost as many have said it is always
difficult to balance the environmental
ambition the impact on competitiveness
as well as interests of consumers we
believe that a reasonable balanced
compromise has been achieved then and it
should be maintained and we're afraid
that any changes at this stage
might jeopardize the agreement reached
the one with the European Parliament
that is it might result in reopening
negotiations on other matters firstly i
have heard everybody say how important
it is to reach first reading agreement
and i also heard germany say that very
very clearly and Peter used sort of
weeks rather than months it should be
soon I take this as a promise from this
council that we cannot go into a pathway
that will take forever and ever and ever
and we all know what is at stake because
if we are not serious about this first
reading agreement we know that there is
a risk that the whole thing will unravel
and we won't get any agreement we think
we've missed an opportunity today and it
means we're exposed to further risks any
adjustments to the compromise packets
from June have to be minor we all must
do our utmost to make sure that the
final decisions are made as soon as
possible the presidency will do its
utmost